[Música]
revista de prensa en directo América de
France 24 Marta Moya ya está con
nosotros en esta mesa de trabajo Marta
buena mañana de miércoles empezamos
entonces con el tema del día el panorama
internacional que veníamos tratando ya
como lo vimos en nuestros noticieros Y
es que Rusia escaló su tono Marta en la
ofensiva Ucrania decretando la
movilización parcial de al menos 300.000
reservistas para combatir en el frente
de batalla como lo Estaba tratando el
periódico ruso como nos calla profta
Buenos días Raúl Pues mira el cosmos
Claudia dice movilización parcial en
Rusia quién tiene derecho a
laplazamiento y quién no será llamado a
filas hace como una descripción de los
soldados que van a tener que acudir al
frente en las próximas semanas porque
Además este decreto entra en vigor hoy
dice pues que todas las categorías de
ciudadanos no están sujetas a este
decreto y que hay excepciones Como por
ejemplo estudiantes y jóvenes que ahora
mismo prestando el servicio militar los
que tengan tres o cuatro hijos o tengan
mujeres en embarazadas con hasta 22
semanas de gestación y aquellas personas
que cuiden a familiares o amigos con
discapacidad o los que sean condenados
Por otra parte los que sí están sujetos
a Bueno pues a participar en la guerra
en Ucrania serán soldados de hasta 35
años y suboficiales de hasta 45 y Bueno
pues priorizando aquellos que ya se
encontraban en la reserva y aquellos que
ya sirvieron en las fuerzas armadas
además el martes ese mismo medio público
publicó ayer una pieza editorial
hablando también de los referendos que
se convocaron en las cuatro regiones
controladas parcialmente por Rusia Así
es dice liberaremos no solo el bombas
sino Rusia En referencia a estos
referendos que tendrán lugar entre el 23
y el 27 de septiembre dice pues el
periodista de este medio que pues estos
referendos cambian el formato de la
operación militar especial porque
todavía no mencionan el término de la
guerra y que se trata de liberar no se
trata perdón de liberar solo las tierras
del Don Bass sino el territorio de Rusia
ocupado por las fuerzas ucranianas dice
textualmente si se ganan los referéndums
resultará que parte de nuestro
territorio está ocupado por las tropas
ucranianas Y entonces
Moscú puede cambiar el régimen de la
operación a otra cosa no es coincidencia
que la duma del estado que ayer aprobó
unas leyes introdujera Pues los
conceptos de ley Marcial tiempo de
guerra o movilización en estos cambios
del Código Penal Bueno cómo lo trata
ahora Marta occidente esta noticia
empezamos por el Wall Street journal en
Estados Unidos tita titula Putin ordena
el reclutamiento de reservistas y
amenaza con una respuesta nuclear dice
el Wall Street journal que hizo el
anuncio en medio de una vacilante
ofensiva rusa y cuando pues Ucrania está
en la contraofensiva en el del país
textualmente el discurso es la señal más
clara hasta ahora de que sí de que siete
meses después del mayor conflicto en
Europa desde la Segunda Guerra Mundial
Rusia Rusia es incapaz de contrarrestar
a Ucrania y occidente que se ha unido en
gran medida frente a la invasión rusa
dice que esta es la primera movilización
parcial de Rusia desde la Segunda Guerra
Mundial que dice el país de España el
país hace un análisis que hace lluís
bassets que dice ante el negro espejo de
la derrota menciona Pues que las armas
nucleares que es un poco la referencia
que ha hecho Putin bueno en este
discurso a la nación denotan una
posición muy precaria para alguien que
sea codeado hasta hace pocos meses con
la élite mundial internacional ya quien
se le presuponía un cierto sentido de la
responsabilidad dice si la movilización
parcial no sirve y sigue siendo inviable
para la estabilidad del régimen la
movilización total a Putin solo le
quedará El dilema entre la aceptación de
la derrota o el botón crear bueno
dejamos a un lado por ahora en la guerra
Marta para cambiar de información porque
ayer china anunció un compromiso su
compromiso Mejor dicho de reunificación
con la isla de Taiwán esto lo hizo y el
global Times este medio afín al partido
comunista chino hizo una dura crítica a
Estados Unidos por sus intenciones de
apoyar a taipei como lo hemos visto
también en las últimas semanas con la
visita de altos representantes políticos
estadounidenses a la isla Sí primero
citamos brevemente al jazeera que recoge
la cita de la portavoz de asuntos de
Taiwán en China y dice que la patria
debe ser reunificada inevitablemente no
se refieren Pues a este compromiso a
largo plazo que tiene China para con la
isla de Taiwán sostiene además que
Beijing ha expresado este deseo pues
Después de varias semanas haciendo
maniobras militares en torno a la isla y
ya citando al global Times sostiene en
su editorial en esta pieza de opinión
que la confusión estratégica sobre
Taiwán de Estados Unidos revela su
esquizofrenia hace pues referencia a la
entrevista de Joe biden donde dijo en
los últimos días que si china ocupará
Taiwán la respuesta de Estados Unidos
sería contundente del lado de taipei
además dice que con la aprobación esta
con estas declaraciones de vaiden queda
claro pues que está en campaña electoral
y que quiere Mostrar su línea más dura
contra China para bueno obtener réditos
electorales muy brevemente Marta vamos a
terminar con el análisis y que dijo el
medio español en el país el habla de
bolsonario y borich en sus discursos en
la asamblea general de Naciones Unidas
Así es cita Pues que América Latina Tuvo
una un gran protagonismo en la primera
sesión de la asamblea general de la ONU
y que borich y bolsonaro borich habló En
tercer lugar bolso raro en primero
mostraron un poco visiones totalmente
antagónicas de América Latina y que se
mostrarán como el agua y el aceite
mientras bolsonaro en plena campaña
mostró un Brasil idílico donde pues la
inflación ha bajado el desempleo ha
bajado han promovido la vacunación
contra el covid 19 aparte bueno a pesar
de que él pues de no estar un poco la
pandemia pues boric se centró en
defender la democracia como la mejor
solución para pues atraer y para
solventar los problemas globales Marte
como siempre Gracias por toda la
información mañana con más revista de
prensa así a Raúl Muchas gracias gracias
a ti Marta y de esta